[Musique]
mais on retrouve mélanie poquet pour son
coup de coeur culture bonsoir ça ce soir
mélanie vous nous emmener en voyage
eh oui soyez prêts à embarquer pour
l'odyssée d'ipo en 80 rêve ipos et
hippocampe fou un rappeur accompagné de
luc adoriez musicien compositeur il vous
emmène en voyage à travers le monde
entier et pas seulement
l'odyssée 10 po et leurs toutes
dernières créations ils sont
actuellement en résidence à la mairie ce
de trappes pour finaliser le tout notre
première idée c'était quoi c'était de
mélanger la musique du monde avec le hip
hop et après avoir listé un petit peu
tous les tous les pays où tous les
genres musicaux qu'on pouvait mélanger
on s'est dit avec tout ça on peut
raconter une histoire et avoir fait le
scénario de du spectacle
voilà qu'on va jouer mais vous avez
assisté à une répétition qu'est ce qui
en fait votre coup de coeur pourquoi
l'avoir sélectionné pour nous en fait
c'est le tout c'est le mélange c'est une
musique qui majore la mise en scène est
très épuré quelques les éléments vont
être ajoutés mais il faut quand fouet
les artistes qui l'accompagnent ont
choisi la simplicité pour le spectateur
parce que pour eux on travaille c'est
pas le plus simple
l'oeil par exemple n'est pas à tirer
dans tous les sens on se laisse penser
porté par les créations vidéo
les dessins et les animations qui sont
signés notamment yannick données et
claude lessard avec les au sarrasin
la musique est très actuel mais lucas
d'aurier et hip hop comme fou il ya même
des consonances cinématographique et
mondiale regardez plutôt
[Musique]
le jour cette faveur
chaque seconde le présent alors pour
vous laisser porter par les odyssées dip
ont rendez vous le samedi 19 janvier à
15 heures à la mairie de trappes et le
spectacle sera suivie par une rencontre
goûtait que les instits hippocampe ou et
bien d'autres informations encore à
retrouver dans l'émission c'est une
culture présentée par vous mélanie merci
pour cette chronique est votre image